last week you and some like-minded tech
analysts
we're down on Tesla walk us through is
this simply because you think this is an
overvalued battery company well I think
first of all it's an overpriced car
company and one of the more interesting
things about Tesla is now comparing it
to other car companies and in September
we think that BMW which is a little
company in Germany sold just about as
many electric cars in the US as Tesla
did about 2000 the i8 naive do you even
know I've been outside I've actually
driven the high yeah and so I'm not
Miller do you think people are aware of
that you're I dunno I think you have to
look at it more as an i3 story because
the i8 while it is an amazing car didn't
sell nearly as many use as the i3 which
is smaller and cheaper one but no I
didn't know actually Jim told me in the
green room and in fact and in fact BMW
their press reports of BMWs is claiming
that almost their entire fleet will be
electric by 2025 well of course
so what Tesla had is it innovation and a
head start in this market other
companies are now catching up to and
they have to become a car manufacturer
and becoming a car manufacturer is a lot
more difficult than becoming a high-tech
darling and and that's the reality here
is that returns are relatively low in
the car business
it's very capital intensive you need
huge networks and all these things when
you're selling 50 thousand cars a year
that they're also the bells and whistles
when you're gonna sell 500,000 to 2
million a year they're essential yeah
you've been the first one to say it's a
good automobile actually yeah you're not
criticizing the product no by all
accounts it's a great product and I
always wonder it looks like BMW wouldn't
be a buyer but I always wondered was
really the play here is for them to
build up a pretty good IP patented
protection right and then sell it to
Ford or GM or something needs to get in
the electric except that the problem is
most other technologies other people's
the battery technology is Panasonic's
and and you know all I have to do is
read their 10k to find that out and so
again they've sold the sizzle here not
the steak and if you look at it Tesla's
market cap it's about half BMWs
but BMW sells two million cars a year
and Tesla sells fifty thousand I know
you're short Tesla well again I'm a
potential purchaser Stephanie so all
right well leave it at that make it a
bit bigger than we've told we learned in
August you were short SolarCity we are
short SolarCity uh then let's just talk
about Elon Musk is it Elon Musk that
you're sure no I think I think Elon Musk
uh certainly his name has added
something to the valuation of both those
companies at the end of the day as we
talked about earlier on Glencore it's
not about personalities it's about the
business model and and SolarCity
we joke is akin to that old movie tin
men with Danny DeVito that there's the
selling aluminum siding door-to-door I
mean the Solar City is basically leasing
you solar panels if you're a residential
customer at what we think is an economic
deal okay but that doesn't make them
subprime you could you compare this to a
subprime finance company yes the
subprime market is a lot different than
guys knocking door-to-door saying can I
sell you a solar panel well not really
because at the end of the day they're
taking credit they're taking consumers
credit and their long-term deal their
20-year deals and and the deal is
dependent for Solar City on the back end
and that's the interesting part in
addition solar city's finances itself
its bonds yield around 8% and that is
certainly junk credit so they have a
portfolio that we think is yielding
about 7% on the leases and they're
financing themselves at rates higher
than that but is this specific to solar
see or are you there with green tech
more general because it about green take
including in China with invest words I
guess gross we're bullish on
installation of solar we think that's
just going to continue and costs are
going to come down all the more reason
be bearish on the residential installers
because again they're they're selling
you power at in Solar city's case at 17
cents a kilowatt hour the average power
building that states residential is
twelve point eight cents and it hasn't
grown and so they've got to get that
rate down solar is slightly more
competitive than the utilities in
California for Solar City but it's not
cheaper than other solar providers and
that's the crux other solar providers
can get it too
cheaper than residentially leasing it
from SolarCity Matt wanna chime in
well I was talking with Jim in the green
room earlier about how amazing I thought
the price to sales ratio was for Tesla
because this is a company with a thirty
billion dollar market cap and it makes
fifty thousand cars a year for it as a
sixty billion market cap and it makes
you know ten million cars a year but a
creation is the issue yes evaluation but
Solar City is even more amazing and I
have it on my terminal if you want to
check it out and green is Solar City I
probably should have put it above
here's Tesla seven and a half times
sales is what it's worth Solar city's
worth fifteen and a half times sales so
the valuation there is even higher
obviously the shorts are already very
active in Tesla I wonder if the
opportunity is even richer in Solar City
then Jim you got to tell me again a
purchaser I'm not that smart are you
short Tesla well again uh we haven't
decided anything we ever disclosed our
position officially in Tesla let's just
let's just say I'm not very positive on
the company and we'll leave it at that
all right he's not very positive on the
company do you want to be sure
Volkswagen here no I don't want to be
short bug no don't want to touch it
no anything I think we'd be looking at
Volkswagen on the long side but but we
have not invested in Volkswagen really I
think they'll survive